I want to tell you a story it's a story
you may think you know but you don't
Guillermo del Toro brings us a dazzling
stop-motion version of the classic tale
of Pinocchio do you recognize the
Stellar cast behind these voices number
one what nine-year-old boy wouldn't say
yes to Pinocchio at least that's how
Gregory Mann felt about accepting the
titular role it's a classic everyone's
watched it and when I found out I got
the role I was over the moon this is the
young actor's first animation credit
he's been in media like Victoria a
series about the early life of Queen
Victoria and the Guernsey literary and
potato peel pie Society something unique
about the way his voice was captured was
that they also recorded his facial
expressions and attached them to
Pinocchio in the film so we really are
seeing Gregory's acting skills
throughout the movie and of course it is
Pinocchio a classic children's book made
more famous by Disney so we do get the
pleasure of some musical numbers I had
almost 80 takes of one of the songs but
I mean he got his result it's a great
number two we all know him as Mike from
stranger things though this isn't Finn's
first time lending his voice to an
animated film ah you made me miss do you
know how long it took for me to set this
up he definitely had a unique experience
working with Guillermo del Toro
he's constantly projecting his voice
especially when he has a mic in front of
him I got to the point where we were
just like really Whispering like very
very very very quietly number three
Guillermo brought on an award-winning
actor to bring count Volpe to life
Christopher Waltz has won two Academy
Awards two Golden Globes two British
Academy film Awards and two Screen
Actors Guild Awards throughout his
career he's been in major films like
Django Unchained and Inglorious Bastards
but couldn't imagine saying no to
Guillermo del Toro about stepping onto
Pinocchio please nourish that passion
for many many years I just get in when
he asks me number four we've got another
one who is most notably known for his
on-screen performances you and McGregor
has won a Golden Globe a prime time Emmy
Award and the bafta Britannia
humanitarian award he was also appointed
officer of the order of the British
Empire for his services to drama and
charity that's a ton of accolades in
this adaptation of Pinocchio we get the
pleasure of hearing him voice Sebastian
J Cricket as a matter of fact I lived
actually lived in the heart of the
wooden boy number five an incredible
actor who has given us Decades of
brilliant performances it seems like
Kate Blanchett can really do it all she
is most notably known for her versatile
acting abilities in major Blockbusters
independent films and Stage work she's
also given her voice to quite a few
animated characters over the years in
movies like how to train your dragon in
Pinocchio she brings the character of
spazatura to life this role was given to
her after a casual conversation with Del
Toro where she says when are we going to
work together again he told her he was
working on Pinocchio and a light bulb
just went off in his head a really
cheeky naughty 12 year old boy and so he
said why don't you play the monkey
number six Ron Perlman gives us some
backstory into the setting of the film
Ron Perlman has been acting for decades
did you see him in the 1987 series
Beauty and the Beast he's no stranger to
the classics in del Toro's version of
Pinocchio Pearlman plays manjafuco who
is a pro-fascist father of Italy he
attempts to use Pinocchio as a soldier
for the country's cause Guillermo's
Pinocchio is set in Mussolini's Italy
which is a fascist backdrop the conceit
of the film is that Pinocchio is the
perfect Soldier because he's not human
so he doesn't ever question orders he
doesn't have fears he's invulnerable
he's all things the perfect Soldier
needs to be number 7. David Bradley has
some big shoes to fill he's stepping
into the iconic role of Geppetto the
wood carver who brings Pinocchio to life
Guillermo del Toro utilizes the darker
and more grotesque depictions of this
childhood story even down to the way he
viewed Geppetto when he was designing
the characters he was thinking back to
the way Geppetto looked in the original
and decided that he was in fact drunk so
after a night of intoxication fueled by
the grief of losing his son Carlo he
discovers that his wooden creation has
come to life he finds himself confused
and honestly utterly terrified in this
version of the film Geppetto is the one
learning the lessons one of those
lessons was learning to accept Pinocchio
for who he was David has a lot to
Grapple with when depicting the complex
character of Geppetto in this version of
the film Geppetto is the one learning
the lessons people are sometimes afraid
of things they don't know you might
recognize David Bradley as filch from
the Harry Potter films or his role as
Walter Frey in Game of Thrones number
eight the voice of the iconic Blue Fairy
while you may have eternal life your
loved ones they do not in the original
Pinocchio we remember the Blue Fairy as
a beautiful winged woman but in del
Toro's version she's giving more of a
Sphynx cat with horns you never know how
long you have with someone until they're
gone Tilda Swinton is a well-known actor
with various accolades she's giving her
voice to only a few animated characters
beforehand in films like Isle of dogs
she has a well-rounded collection of
accolades including including an Academy
Award and a British Academy film award
number nine he's giving us the black
rabbits Tim Blake Nelson is an actor and
playwright known for his impressive
character work he's been playing
characters for decades his film credits
include holes Oh Brother Where Art Thou
and the Incredible Hulk we get to see
his performance as the black rabbits
when Pinocchio gets stuck in a lucid
dream Del Toro explains Pinocchio has
strange moments of lucid dreaming
bordering on hallucinations with black
rabbits there are actually a lot of dark
undertones that we find out during this
lucid dream sequence Del Toro also gives
us some insight into the backstory of
some of these characters for example did
you know that the Blue Fairy is supposed
to be the spirit of a girl who has
passed away we tend to call something
disneyfied but a lot of people forget
how powerfully disturbing the best
animated Disney movies are including
these kids being turned into donkeys in
Pinocchio number 10. we've got another
seasoned actor in the credits John
Turturro is most notably known for his
contribution to the independent film
movement he has been in over 60 feature
films and has worked with people like
Spike Lee Adam Sandler and the Coen
Brothers The Big Lebowski John has
actually worked in more Spike Lee films
than any other actor they first worked
together on do the right thing in 1989
and as of 2008 he plays the character of
dottore and del Toro's Pinocchio number
11. he dropped everything for this role
Bern Gorman has been lucky enough to
work with Guillermo del Toro a few times
now he takes you on a journey it's
dreamlike and it's wonderful and I'm
glad to be involved he's also a huge fan
of Mark gustafson's work and stop motion
in general so the movie was right up his
alley he placed the priest who could be
considered pretty Pleasant in the
beginning but quickly turns towards
fascism throughout the movie number 12
born and raised in Italy she fits right
into the film setting voicing the role
of one of the twin daughters Francesca
fanty is no stranger to any form of
media one of her first breakout
performances was the leading role of
Filomena corado in distant Vision a live
Cinema experience production that ran
for a month at UCLA she even performed a
one-woman comedy show that won the Ada
artistic director Achievement Award for
best actress in comedy voice acting
comes naturally for her as well she lent
her voice to magior in the movie Luca
another sighting in the harbor this time
I know we are setting up a reward
someone's gotta win a nice prize and was
also in Madagascar 3 Europe's Most
Wanted Guillermo del Toro takes a Disney
classic and gives it a stellar twist
what do you think of his adaptation of
Pinocchio do you recognize any of the
voices behind the characters let us know
in the comments
[Music]